we now turn to developments overseas
tonight iranian-backed militias
reportedly firing rockets at u.s forces
in syria
following this week's air strikes damage
is still being assessed
at the u.s base in eastern syria so far
no injuries have been reported here with
reaction
south carolina senator lindsey graham
senator i don't know if i'm allowed to
talk about an off the record
conversation we had
but this is exactly what you predicted
to me would happen
yeah so here's the game plan uh number
one the iranians are playing
president biden like a fiddle uh the
ayatollah shawn
is a religious nazi hitler wanted a
master race
the ayatollah wants a master religion
they're trying to drive us
out of syria and iraq so they can
dominate
syria iraq and iran the shia crescent
they're trying to build a nuclear weapon
to hold the world hostage
and one day destroy the state of israel
they're on the path
to accomplish all that unless we make a
correction now
i've never been more worried than i am
right now about a war between iran and
israel
well you know i think the biggest under
well the most underreported story was
the chinese the russians are now giving
weapons to the iranians so they can
fight their proxy war in the rest of the
middle east
i don't know am i the only person on
national tv that seems to notice that's
a big problem
you're the only one that talks about a
lot of things number one the russians
and the chinese believe
that what's bad for us is good for them
they're making a mistake with iran
again the iranians want to dominate
syria iraq and iran
they want to build a nuclear weapon to
hold the world hostage and destroy the
state of israel
the state of israel is in a bad spot
here how much longer to the way
do they wait before the act i don't
think you can trust the united states
with israel's security what bind doesn't
understand
is who the ayatollah is the ayatollah
has a game plan that doesn't
include christians jews or moderate
muslims
shia or sunni so this is the most
important event since the 30s we have a
chance to keep iran on the ropes
we have a chance to keep them in a box
but every day they get stronger
because biden doesn't understand the
nature of the threat
i you know if if i'm right and
if my observations and the observations
now many people are correct that
joe is seems out of it on a regular
basis
does raise questions about you know how
strong he
is and how capable he is of even
understanding it then it raises
questions about who's making the
decisions
i would imagine that these hostile
regimes from
russia to china to north korea to the
iranian muellers to radical islamic
terrorist groups they probably are
feeling somewhat emboldened now
is that a wrong observation
well we're cutting our military's budget
brian's budget increased non-defense
spending by 17 percent
defense spending less than inflation
we're withdrawing from afghanistan where
we had a few thousand troops to keep al
qaeda and isis at bay
but here's my message to your viewers
tonight the iranian regime
are religious nazis they would kill all
the jews that they could
they would dominate the mideast with a
former religion that would make the
world an
unbearable place to live and they would
come after us
they're trying to drive us out of the
mideast they understand that biden is
weak
and he's making the world a much more
dangerous place by showing weakness
when trump kills solomani it reset our
relationship with iran
everything trump has accomplished biden
is undercutting
a pretty scary scenario senator thank
you for keeping us updated we appreciate
it hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else